let's make this a second feature and
then let's cut it up into segments and
then we'll upload that onto YouTube as
part of our marketing strategy
what is beast mode so beast mode is the
behind the scenes documentary of space
waves it shows the making of space waves
and all the ups and downs we experienced
as we made this micro budget Indie
feature and so you'll see how you know
10 of us starting with ten thousand
dollars we went along and we did
principal photography and we did posts
and pickups and all the different ups
and downs and how we ended at about
fifty thousand dollars over this five
year long journey so you're gonna see
everything it takes to make a small
independent movie
when did you decide you were making a
documentary was it during making of the
feature film so beast mode was one of
those things where at first it started
with myself and the first AC Rebecca
um thinking hey let's make just like a
little 20-minute thing that shows some
behind the scenes of making space waves
and then when space waves turned into
this huge five year long journey with
all this crazy challenges and things we
had to overcome this documentary became
bigger and bigger because the story was
just so huge and so when it came time to
shoot the interviews to talk about the
b-roll that we shot on set and
everything the interviews ended up going
for hours because everyone's just
telling all these crazy stories you know
of you know extras not showing up
getting kicked out of locations and the
Mustang breaking down and losing the
radio tower and just everything you can
think of going wrong so there was so
much there was so much to talk about so
this documentary just turned into this
big thing and then that the
documentaries final run time ended up
being like an hour and 48 minutes which
is longer than space waves the movie
itself which is pretty funny
you barely had enough crew to shoot
space waves how are you doing behind the
scenes footage I'm just any chance we
could just in between
um I would I'm always a person that's
filming and taking photos on my phone so
I would shoot stuff Rebecca would shoot
stuff
um I had my sister when she wasn't doing
production design have a like a T3i
camera or something or a Canon 80d
whatever shooting behind the scenes
shots uh in between
um and so we just kind of
um just got footage any way we could I
would say next movie I would love to
have a dedicated person on set to just
capture behind the scenes video and
photo that's going to be really
essential but for space waves and beast
mode it was just kind of we had these
footage dumps where we would we would
ask hey who you know from this week we
want to grab everyone's iPhones and just
grab all the photos and videos that you
guys have taken and so a lot of the cool
videos or whatever came from just like
oh the sound person shot something or
the gaffer shot something on their phone
and ended up being a great clip even
though they only shot a few things you
know there's stuff like that
how long did it take you to sift through
all the footage for the binds um it took
a very long time I mean we worked on
this documentary for years so
it was it was just
yeah like I said it's like an hour and
48 minutes it's very big and very
ambitious I think it originally was like
two hours and 20 minutes when we had
like our first kind of rough cut and so
it's just it's been such a huge project
and so to cut it down and to go through
everything
um has has taken a very long time plus
you're also weaving through a story yes
so it's its own form of Storytelling and
yeah and we had to figure out
um one of the tricky things with
figuring out what is the
meta narrative like the big narrative
and what are what are the narratives for
each of these individual kind of
segments of the story and we tried to
make sure I don't know it was kind of
like the story kind of just came to us
as we were editing the interviews and
stuff and we realized okay the kind of
thesis and the message of beast mode is
like young filmmakers doing whatever it
takes overcoming every challenge every
step of the way to make a feature film
and so that was kind of the thing that
the theme that just kept coming up and
so we tried to structure the the
documentary around that and we decided
okay we're not going to shy away from
the challenges we're going to show the
challenges we're going to show people's
disappointments and people's
frustrations as they're making space
waves because it makes it makes the film
that much greater because it shows how
much we conquered and it shows how much
um
how much Redemption and how much we all
grew through the process
how much extra did it cost to make beast
mode it didn't cost that much extra it
was mostly just the hours that we had to
put into making it because it was myself
and the first AC Rebecca
um just doing this project and so there
was a lot of times where things were
slow because we were working on other
things or whatever and we had to come
back to it and the only things that we
really the only real cost was paying for
sound design to get the sound leveled
out because you know interviews and
there's loud b-roll and then there's all
this stuff happening so that was the one
thing we paid for to make sure that it
all sounded good and then I did the
color grade and Becca did an initial
like first sound pass and stuff so we
tried to just take care of it all
ourselves and then I think yeah I think
sound was the only thing we paid for
was it your strategy to make two movies
for the price of one
not at the beginning yeah because at the
beginning it was oh this will just be a
small thing to accompany the film just
like a little behind the scenes 20
minute thing but then you know as it
went along it just got bigger and bigger
and then it became the strategy okay
let's make this a second feature and
then let's cut it up into segments and
then we'll upload that onto YouTube as
part of our marketing strategy so it was
like okay movies out and now you're
gonna see every week you're going to see
behind the scenes about the making of
This film and so not only is it a really
cool Keepsake for us for the sentimental
types that we want to relive the
experience and see it and hear everyone
telling the stories and stuff but it's
also a very um strategic thing for our
marketing campaign and so it keeps it
fresh in people's in people's um as
they're scrolling they're seeing more
and more content about space waves and
beast mode and makes people appreciate
the film that much more
um and so you know I think all of us
when we see a film we like we want to go
learn about the making of it and get to
know the people behind it who made the
film so it became an essential
um part of our process and our our
social media rollout and our marketing
and everything
when it's all said and done how many
episodes will there be uh 15 15 okay
great when did you film all of the cast
and crew interviews so we filmed those
um in Fall 2018 so that was right after
we shot the bulk of principal
photography
um we ended up having to do some
interviews later in 2019 just because we
ended up shooting more stuff like at the
space Tower and all this stuff so we had
to shoot a couple more interviews to
talk about some of that stuff but I
would say if you know if you are making
a behind the scenes documentary shoot
the interviews as close to the action as
possible while it's still fresh in
everyone's Minds because when we showed
beast mode to people everyone was like
oh my gosh I totally forgot about that
or I didn't even remember I said that or
you know so you wanna you wanna make
sure you shoot it while it's fresh in
everybody's minds and that'll get you
the most accurate and the most
passionate version of the store story
have you thought about releasing beast
mode as a full documentary yeah and that
was the initial plan was to release it
just in full on YouTube and then we
pivoted and we're like no let's release
it in Parts over the course of the
summer and then we thought okay we'll
just put out the full length right after
that but we had to do a lot of uh you
know strategizing and figuring out the
best way to release this thing
um and Becca wanted to go to festivals
with it so we kind of came up with a um
an agreement that like we're gonna
release it episodically but then the
full documentary is gonna like hopefully
go to some festivals and you know it's
kind of it's in a feature form
um and so hopefully it'll get into some
festivals and do good things for Becca
and me and the whole Space waves film
and the crew and everybody involved so
we'll see what happens with that but
that remains to be seen